good morning believe nation today's
message is ah right you see it's been a
while it's my turn right
good morning believe nation today's
message is examine where you are over to
you Tom Hanks in the beginning I was
just thrilled to know that someone was
asking me to be in a movie and I thought
that was all that was required and as
long as they keep asking everything
everything will fall fall into place
mm-hmm and I think I had to become
dissatisfied with my own process you
know five or six movies in where I was
feeling that that I was not I was not
bringing I was not bringing to the work
anything other than that anything other
than that instinct and that's when I
realized that you know okay I'm part of
me got older and I think even if you're
as old as 29 you you have a different
set of chops and perspective you have a
different believe it or not wisdom that
you did when you were 24 and I think
about every five years I went through
some sort of process of reexamining
where I was in life you know as a man as
well as an actor and thinking like guess
what I'm 36 now and there's a whole
world of movies that I can't make
anymore because I can no longer I don't
want to play the young man who's trying
to figure out life I want to play a man
of bitter compromise I want to play
somebody who's who's been through
something so it's a never-ending process
I think of examining where you are in
life as a human being and then
transposing that so it's gonna be
reflected in your work somehow so what
do you think the only thing I can give
example is my own life I was looking to
be a wait how old are you 29
did you talk about 29 that's a good
sentence my career change came out about
two about a year and a half no two years
ago or so I wanted to be a cop so I was
working as a security guard to gain some
experience and I did it for about a year
and a half and just a night life working
on the weekend
missing out on all the salsa parties up
me not being able to see my friends
always in jet lag so I did the swing
shift which meant that I would do two
days into overnights constantly so every
day was jet lag for me I'd only get like
four hours of sleeping and I wake up
anxious or uncomfortable gained a lot of
weight and just it was not a great
experience for me so I had to
re-evaluate my priority which was hard
because I was working two years to be a
cop already at that point a lot of
investing into that doing tests and
physicals and all that kind of stuff my
resume getting everything ready I looked
at where I wanted to be in five or ten
years and I want to I knew I wanted a
family I knew that I wanted to have kids
to be there for them on the weekends and
make sure it was just a regular schedule
9:00 to 5:00 to some extent right so I
did a whole career change there started
from scratch went into sales and then
reality myself an opportunity came with
TDs and then I looked at myself and what
really makes me happy and and then took
another plunge so I honestly don't know
where I'll be in five years
I knew in all these jobs I knew what was
important to me so it was sort of my
compass
there's always room to change direction
and you know the the fear of I've
invested this amount of money or this
amount of studying or whatever it is
right into this that I can't quit that's
not true if you feel that is really not
right for you that it's not gonna make
you happy in the long term then
reevaluate and look for your passions I
like it so for context I hired Alex like
I had hunted him away from a job that he
had to run TDS so the hardcore fans know
who he is the new people I go who's this
guy so you know there you go I think for
me people make the mistake of not
continuing to change the things that
they're working on as they grow as a
human being and you see it a lot with
entrepreneurs will those start a
business and they'll be really excited
by it and then their own interests and
passions will change but their business
doesn't change with them and then going
to work becomes work it becomes a job it
becomes less interesting the thing that
you were all excited about leaving your
working for the man to start your own
company by now now you're working for
the man again you've booked yourself in
and
hate being boxed in and it's one of the
biggest mistakes that as you grow as a
human being because you're gonna grow
like you know alex is 29 Tom Hanks talks
about being 29 you compare yourself to
where you were five years ago or ten
years ago your interests have change
you've grown you've matured you've
learned new things maybe you don't want
to be out partying as much or like
whatever like your interests have
changed and so that has to be reflected
in the work that you do otherwise you'll
stop being creative and you'll start
hating your job or hating your business
and so I think instead of only waiting
till you're super frustrated and waiting
to like I can't stand this thing anymore
five years later you've been doing it
already doing it for two or three years
that's like it's absolute hell and then
only to the point where like I can't
take anymore I'm gonna quit where a lot
of people get that with their jobs or
business constantly evaluating
constantly trying new things constantly
trying to evolve the work that you're
doing to be reflection of you where my
business is always in a reflection of
what I'm interested in
even the YouTube channel has only been
around for five or six years and
forgetting about the content that I've
talked about has changed over the years
the message is still the same about
believe and trying to help inspire
entrepreneurs but how I've executed it
has changed like the top ten series is a
relatively new thing that didn't exist
on the channel multiple years ago I
still like it I'm still learning from it
if I stop liking the top tens and doing
the work then I'll stop putting them out
there and we won't have them anymore on
the channel but I'll be evolving into
something new and that's part of the
drive is I like being creative and you
guys like being creative as well and if
you can't be creative anymore because
you know the the success you've had is
now changed to prevent you from going
forward then that's where you start to
struggle you have to get bored you look
for other things and so I would just
encourage you to do that constantly the
constant think about how you can make
things better if you have a creative
idea find a small way to get started on
it and not get to the point where you
hate your life and you hate your
business and you hate your job and then
you're forced to make a change we don't
normally do this so I'm gonna throw out
something different I want to ask you
something maybe the viewers will be
interested in - I like when you say that
you know you will need to constantly
evaluate yourself alright there are
certain things you can pay attention to
in your life that you think are sort of
signs that you should be evaluating it
would be hard for me - every morning to
wake up and and every morning reassess
because then you're not really giving an
opportunity for the things you were
trying that are new to really grow to
fruition rightly so did they say about
fitness or you should give it a certain
amount of time to do certain fitness
program see if it's actually working so
is there any advice you can give or
something that they can that people can
work like a sort of a lighthouse right
in there and missing father what do you
look for like the lighthouse in the fog
yeah two things one is on the negative
side was on the positive side the
negative is if I find myself doing
something that I hate doing constantly I
need to find a way to change it either I
need to stop doing it completely or I
need to give it to somebody else to do
like is it important enough to my
business that it has to happen if so let
me bring on somebody who likes that work
and I'm gonna stop doing it so for TDs
booking the meetings you know managing
my calendar I was I was bad at it wasn't
happening it wasn't going to the classes
I wasn't meeting with as many people as
I needed to and and it was important for
the business that happened and so I gave
it to my assistant who manages all of my
Evan Carmichael stuff I also gave her
now my run events also stuff and it's
great like it's in my calendar I get to
set her the rules it's happening now but
I didn't want to do it myself and every
time I looked at it it just I just
didn't want to do it but it had to get
done sometimes I'll just drop projects
because I look at the work like I don't
want to do that work that sucks I don't
want to do that and so I drop it and I
may be something that is profitable that
you can give to somebody else to run or
maybe it's not profitable and then you
just drop it over onto something else
like the sunk cost idea hey I've
invested all this time and money into
becoming a cop and is you know what I
don't like this anymore
I'm gonna drop it and move on every time
I'm feeling like I hate this work that
I'm doing and even if it's even if it's
a like a 10 minutes pain in the day if
that's consistently happening then I I
will find ways to eliminate that the
other side is a positive where I want to
do something I'm excited by something I
have this idea to test something and you
know I try
he gets to live with it I have crazy
ideas that I want to go and try and
sometimes they work and sometimes they
don't and more often than not it's
usually pretty good but sometimes they
don't work but I when I get an idea that
I want to try I go out and I just start
doing it I find a way to make it happen
even on a small scale to see if I like
it if I'm excited by it but if it makes
me come alive if I want to keep doing it
I would default to taking the risk and
trying versus taking the safe path an
example TDS we just changed our floors
and we brought in these new floors that
I would I would never have picked these
floors they're way brighter than I
thought I wanted a dark wood and these
are way brighter than I ever would have
thought I ever would have picked I
looked a sample but I can't I can't pick
this this is this is ugly like I would
never picked it and then I walked into a
store and I saw it on the floor like oh
man that's a nice looking floor I gotta
get that floor and then we went and I
brought Alex and and who else it was
Nina my sister and another instructor
and we had them dance on the floor and
is all of the all the rest of how it's
really different than what we have and I
know it's gonna work and all of that and
seem the same thing is going through my
head too like it's very different than
what we have it may not work but I
remember the feeling of loving it when I
walked in it's the only floor that I
walked in of any of the places that we
visited and I loved it and so you know
what I have to do it even if it's a fail
even if we have the rip of the floor and
that's like a you know five six thousand
dollar mistake that I made I've got to
do it I have to do it I have to do it
and so when I get those creative ideas I
just start taking immediate action on
even though it may not make sense for
the people around me as sometimes you
witness an experience so both of those
like that's the constant evaluation
there's something you're doing that you
don't like then find a way to stop doing
it whether delegating it or just
stopping it and if there's something
that you want to start doing then find a
way to start doing it consistently even
like taking you away from your job was a
risk right like they were safer options
that I could have gone with for the
skill set that we needed for the like
admin work to
the school which wasn't something that
you're like the best at yeah but I
didn't want just an admin person I
wanted somebody who would grow and build
the company so Alex was a risk like we
had a lot of conversations till late at
night and and I needed to at least know
that I gave my best effort to make it
work and if you said no whatever awesome
we'll move on someone else but you said
yes it might have sunk the company it
didn't it didn't what we're doing it but
like that risk like that knowing I don't
want to take always the safe path that
there's something that I'm curious about
I have to figure out a way to at least
try to make it happen at the risk of
losing something because I don't want to
always just play the safe path and then
wonder what if like what if I talked to
Alex and what if I gave him this or what
if right and then stuck with somebody
who's just doing an okay job so that's
it awesome thank you so the question
that they today is are you finding that
you need to revalue self and if so where
are you at right now leaving the
comments below
we will join in the discussion finally
we want to give a quick shout out to
Carrie Lee from Carrie Lee art comm
Carrie thank you so much you're buying a
copy of my book it really means a lot to
me those you're watching if you want a
chance at a shout out in a future
episode of one of these videos make sure
to pick up a copy of the book it's
pretty good
part of it I you haven't given me the
are you gonna give me a free coffee no
no you gotta buy your copy I'm an
employee I should you gotta buy your
copy pick up a copy emailing you receipt
so we can keep track and give you the
bonuses thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
expresso give me go